Deputy leader Angela Rayner who is in
Westminster uh thanks very much for
being with us so what do you make of the
events of the day
I mean it's utter chaos and looking at
the 1922 committee there they look like
rabbits in their headlights they haven't
got a clue what they're doing and the
scary thing is we could have a situation
where we have a prime minister of this
country with zero Monday I mean it's
pretty clear they've lost the confidence
of the British public
and they just don't have a clue what
they're doing they've got no plan no
leader and they they're trying to cling
on to power like somehow being the Prime
Minister forming a cabinet is some sort
of game for them when the rest of the
country are praying paying the price for
it it makes me kind of really frustrated
and angry because people's lives have
been affected by their silly little
games and I just cannot believe the
absurdity of what we're seeing and what
we're witnessing
um but uh the conservative party rules
are conservative party rules you you it
doesn't look at least like you're going
to get your election
I mean you say conservative party rules
to their rules but as you were saying
before I don't even think they trust
their membership at the moment and it
seems to me like they're going around uh
trying to make it up as they go along to
say nothing to see here and try and just
drag any old MP who they're willing to
put in front of the people and say this
is who we've got for you running scared
of a general election because they know
that the public are the real ones who
should be deciding how the future of
this country is governed because they've
lost the will of the people and the
confidence now because it crashed our
economy they've ripped up the manifesto
that they stood on and they've done more
u-turns than a cul-de-sac I mean it's
embarrassing not just here but also
abroad to see the Fiasco the chaos that
we're witnessing at the moment and they
need to put the country first and not
the party first and they need the
general election and a Monday
but you might be coming up against Boris
Johnson again
I mean that in itself I find absolutely
absurd their own MPS finally got rid of
Boris Johnson after he'd lied to the
British people broke the rules chaos
sleaze Scandal that engulfed that Boris
Johnson's leadership and now all of a
sudden they think that's going to save
the country people haven't forgotten
what happened during the pandemic the
fact that Downing Street became the
worst offenders for breaking the rules
of any other address in the UK when
people weren't able to see their loved
ones if that's their solution to this
problem then they're going to get even
more thumped at a general election
because the British public do not like
being taken for Falls
but isn't the one thing we've learned
from this chaos is the nature of the
fiscal hole or the black hole and and
isn't that
um proof that you really need to fix
your own plan for the economy and do you
accept that you're going to have to look
at spending cuts
well we've been very clear that we'd set
out our plan which would our fiscal
rules would mean there'd be no
expenditure without showing where that
money would come from so for example
even though that mini budget has pretty
much been ripped apart and you turned on
there is still the lift on the the cap
on Bankers bonuses when ordinary working
people are facing the squeeze we've said
that we'd end the charitable status of
school so that we could give children
free School meals we've said that we
deal with non-dom status so that we can
get more doctors and nurses in our NHS
we've got a plan we said that we'd put a
levy on a windfall tax on the Energy
company so we're not putting it on the
national debt we have a fiscal plan for
growth in this country
sorry to interrupt but with the level of
spending in that plan survive contact
with the with the markets
well as I've just suggested to you and I
think that you know it was the CEO of
Tesco recently that said the labor party
is the only team on the field with a
plan for growth at the moment we set out
so far as we can what our plan is and
we've made it very clear to the British
public we would not put any spending
plans forward that is not economically
sound that we would make sure that
people can see where the money's coming
from and we've not even had an obr
forecast or the ons on the latest U-turn
from the conservatives so nobody knows
whether their plan is in any way
fiscally sound now even with the u-turns
because we've not had that independent
scrutiny of what they've come up with it
is a company we are getting in it yeah
we are getting an obr statement uh at
the end of uh October oh yeah but we had
that we had the statement last week and
we've still not had that statement
independent scrutiny of their plans it's
a mess all right Angela Arena got to
leave it there thank you very much
indeed